hot breath well when you're talking
about uh like
editing your joke and the audience not
understanding it when you say a joke one
way
and then you're like they're not
understanding it how the how are you
then editing it down what are the things
you're manipulating to make them
understand it in the future keep it
simple i always think about mcdonald's
okay
what would mcdonald's do you know if
this has got to be
it's got to appeal to everybody and it's
got to be
easy to understand it's like a website
you ever go on a website you're like
what you read legal jargon you're like
what the is this
i think you've got to just make it so
it's
buttons and letters and colors you know
just
easy peasy to figure out so you want to
walk into that store and get it
so it's like maybe they don't understand
the premise so you need to be more clear
on what it is you're even trying to say
with the premise
of course i mean look at chris rock he
repeats his premise three times
you know women can't go back in
lifestyle
they can't go back in lifestyle women
that's just him making sure you get it
you know exactly what he's saying nice
simple is better
you